c'est hier soir en direct sur le plateau
de thé pmp que nous avons assisté à un
échange pour le moins tendues entre le
chroniqueur rené malleville et benjamin
castaldi
mais puisqu un coût 3 et tu te crois toi
là ça arrive les lensois jouent ils
parlaient alors qu'il était question du
professeur didier raoult est attaqué en
justice pour mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui
rené malleville avaient préparé des
informations complémentaires qui
souhaitait livrer en plateau une prise
de parole tourner en dérision par
benjamin castaldi et jean michel maire
mais de quoi il faut dire que les infos
de rené était dense et l'humeur en
plateau assez légère mais très vite rené
s'est senti insulté par les rires de ses
camarades et a menacé de quitter le
plateau suis pas là pour faire de la
après l'émission de nombreux internautes
lui ont affiché son soutien sur les
réseaux castaldi et irrespectueux il le
fait à chaque fois que rené parle il a
un problème avec rené ça devient très
lourd
il faut recadrer benji jean-michel leurs
blagues pourries 116 sur rené le pastis
et marseille ça va bien cinq minutes
j'étais dégoûté pour lui hier pas pris
au sérieux alors qu'il était fier de son
taf
cet incident est pour lui la moquerie de
troupes il ya donc annoncé hier soir sur
facebook son intention de quitter
définitivement les missions aujourd'hui
rené attend des excuses de la part de
ceux qui se sont moqués de lui alors
benjamin et jean-michel ont ils été trop
loin
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
séquence se dire et je vais dire aussi
moi aussi j'ai beaucoup rigolé voilà et
c'est vrai que koné me fait rire voilà
chaque fois donné l'info et puis voilà
alors oui non vous ou vos petites
banques à vos bernard gnecchi n'étiez
pas là oui oui mais j'ai regardé
l'émission évidemment et oui j'ai trouvé
que c'était un peu lourd c'était un peu
trop parce que rené on l'a d'or c'est
quelqu'un d'entier détriment sympathique
qui ne maîtrise pas comme nous non plus
cette aisance peut-être à la télévision
parce qu'il vient de débarquer ce mec
qui parle naturellement c'est une vraie
nature c'est un vrai personnage adorable
passionnant moi je suis très content
pour la gauche et benjamin jean miche
prouve qu'il allait oui et alors nos
copains cessé de gamme assez de sales
gosses jean michel mr et benji c'est de
sales gosses voilà c'est comme ça qu'il
faut le prendre mais même d'irak dean et
moi on a rigolé hier on va voir son tir
alors nous voir mais c'est pour ça oui
dire qu'ils sont menacés d'être moins
mais nous on est tous allés trop loin
à l'exception peut-être deux peut-être
de delphine et de et de raymond qui ont
été proches de grosses sommes mais on a
rigolé parce qu'ils répondent en direct
il y avait un rire un peu communicatif
un peu potache un peu un peu un peu nul
comme dans un diner de cons finalement
sauf que je trouve que le dîner a duré
trop longtemps et qu'on sait tous on est
tous le con de quelqu'un et je trouvais
que effectivement moi j'étais très mal à
l'aise après à la fin de l'émission
j'ai dit à rené et gt gt mal à l'aise
parce qu'en fait c'était un peu oui
c'était un peu dégradant moi je pense
que j'ai llaro n'est pas ce que je vais
vous dire ce qui m'a écrit
est ce qu'on s'est dit avec rené puisque
rené sera avec nous dans ce n'est pas
tout c'est pas ses chroniques
quoi qu'ils fassent toute façon il
offrira même mois ci pour ça qu'il est
pris au départ c'est que c'est un
personnage exceptionnel c'est un
personnage lacroix c'est ce qu'on disait
avec delphine tout à l'heure mais il ya
peut-être bien entendu alors en fait moi
ce matin rené j'aurais peut-être
l'occasion de l'union après je voulais
vraiment lui envoya mais un médecin je
dirais que je n'ai pas son numéro et
c'est pour ça qu'on s'est téléphoné ce
matin pour pour en parler parce que moi
j'avais j'en avais gros sur le coeur
parce que rené je le trouve adorable
c'est quelqu'un d'authentix et quelques
uns des régions qui a un accent où il me
fait penser à mon grand père mon grand
père aussi quand il parlait on
comprenait pas parce qu'il avait
l'accent alsacien et ben rené il a
l'accent du sud
et quand il a sorti sa feuille avec son
écriture en attaché qu'il a mis ses
lunettes pour lire ce qu'il a fait j'ai
trouvé ça mais adorable et ça allait
trop loin hier jean pascal en fait il
n'y a pas de problème parce que c'est
l'esprit de l'émission ci dessous
c'est vrai que la blague un petit peu
dur et mais on est tous comme on le dit
une grande famille on est une bande de
copains alors c'est vrai qu'on se
chambrer là c'est un petit peu dérapé
c'est l'homme là c'était cette épaisse
et des sens même de tps et rigoler et
c'est vrai qu'on est une bande de
copains il faut pas pas il faut qu'on
reste une bande de copains ssatp mp
c'est une grande famille il faut pas le
gâcher pas exactement dans ces parties
rené oui ah bah il fait plus que partie
la famille c'est bon c'est mon chouchou
il le sait ouais il le sait que c'est
mon chouchou je laime vraiment besoin
d'aidé moi à moi je suis entre le oui et
le non d'accord vous expliquer j'ai vécu
avec gilles verdez quand je suis venu il
ya deux ans vous souvenez que le
fauteuil où il m'avait dit ta gueule
pernikoff et à l'extérieur j'avais vu
des gens qui les lie mais vous auriez dû
vous battre vous auriez jamais dû
laisser passer ce qui se passe aussi sur
rodez réalité en réalité je vous
expliquez moi j'étais derrière je
regardais la télé chez moi hier puisque
je n'étais pas sûr très vite et est en
fait un véritable décalage entre ce que
nous sommes tous ensemble puisque en
réalité il ya énormément de
bienveillance entre nous un surya
personne ne s'entend pas rené moi j'ai
découvert ya pas longtemps d'ailleurs je
suis son imitateur favori il me l'a dit
il m'a dit l'autre fois c'est un mec
entier
c'est un mec spontanée hier il a bossé
son sujet il essayait de s'exprimer
alors c'est vrai que c'est quand même
très difficile parce que lui comme moi
je me mets dans le un peu à sa place
puisque je suis pas un
je suis pas un pro des médias quand vous
essayer de tenir un sujet comme ça vous
êtes concentré qui est ultra sérieux et
puis et puis hommage à ce monsieur quand
même un qui a travaillé avec gaston
defferre qui a fait des choses
formidables dans sa vie assure très
engagé à marseille mais je veux dire le
mec il défend raul qui a le droit de
défendre out moi je le défends aussi il
le défend avec ses tripes et on le coupe
3 4 fois après de l'autre côté je vous
parle de benjamin je connais -
jean-michel mais benjamin est un ami de
trente ans je sais que c'est un mec bien
que de temps en temps ça peut être un
gamin et qui peut se marrer avez-vous et
puis c'est arrivé même avec moi cette
semaine sur le low cost vous savez quand
je parlais de hold up étaient tous les
deux en train de rigoler comme de
bananes et moi j'étais là en train
d'essayer de défendre mon truc ça arrive
après rené tout le monde aime on les
aime je sais que les réseaux sociaux
l'aiment
benjamin et jean-michel c'est pareil les
gens l'aiment enfin je veux dire on est
on est une famille on essaye de se
donner tous
tout ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui c'est pas
sérieux c'est pas du premier degré c'est
du second degré donc s'il vous plaît
regarder cette émission pour vous
divertir
ne la prenaient part et ne la recevait
pas autrement et rené un teint je t'ai
milow pour mener sur le bateau et je
sais que je laime de ou ford et kelly
ben moi j'ai fait mon retour sur ce
bateau en parlant de famille c'est pour
ça que j'ai ni oui ni non parce que je
je comprends pas que ça puisse aller au
delà de 2 comment ça se passe avec nous
en loge parce qu'il ya les loges
il ya aussi les missions pour dire la
vérité et quand on est tous en loge on a
tellement une complicité on se dit
tellement tous tout ce qu'on a à dire
que je me dis que mon plateau ça ne
devrait pas arriver ce genre de choses
donc moite à l'heure j'ai vu rené et je
comprenais c'est un petit peu son
désarroi et moi qui étais
téléspectatrices de ce que j'ai vu là je
me suis dit hé bien je les reconnais
bien ces deux venaient là à se moquer de
lui comme ça et c'était vraiment un truc
familial pour le coup et est
généralement dans les repas ça se passe
aussi comme ça malheureusement pense que
oui vraiment non moi je comprends oui
pour répondre tout de suite il hier on a
été trop loin on s'est pas rendu compte
de ce qui se passait moi d'abord je
tiens à dire qu'au début je rigolais
comme tout le monde je rigolais quand on
a mis la voiture piégée rené j'étais
mort de s'aguerrir avant chaque fois
sacré mais ça chaque fois qu'il faut
pardonner s'est construit à chaque fois
quand on fait une séquence avec rené
c'est tout le temps de rôle ce qui est
rond n'est on a dépassé parce que
c'était trop long et moi je suis un peu
comme rené quand on vient à la télé on
vient à la télé on dit comme ça on
réalise pas on réalise pas il me dit
tout ce qu'on dit ou ce qu'on pense et
on croit que ça on va changer le monde
quand on vient là on pense qu'on va
changer le monde ce qui est pas vrai et
maintenant je voudrais juste dire à rené
il le sait je l'adorent renaît donc ce
qu'il a fait hier il a dit avec ses
tripes il a bien travaillé et concernant
les deux jean michel et benjamin c'est
des monstres de télé mine de rien
maintenant on peut dire ce qu'on veut
benjamin c'est un monstre de télé jean
michel ça fait onze ans qu'il est là
c'est devenu un monstre de télé c'est
l'adn tpm pc comme ça et moi je voudrais
juste dire aux gens hier oui on a
déconné tous il y en a pas un qui est
sorti de on est tous responsables de ce
qui s'est passé même vous cyril mais je
veux je tiens à dire quand même que
benjamin et jean-michel quand moi je
m'embrouille à exit verdez comme moi
j'ai des ouragans ici quand moi je me
suis engueulé avec matthieu delormeau
les premiers à me rappeler derrière à
m'inviter manger des pizzas
c'est jean-michel le premier qui me dit
benjamin quand je m'embrouille avec lui
sur les salaires des acteurs vient à la
maison parce que tu raconte des
conneries ils ont pas un fond méchant
fier on a merdé
mais ils ont pas un fond méchant ils en
veulent pas à rené et rené c'est un gars
formidable et il faut qu'il soit tpm
péroné samedi 10 à qui veut
oui moi ça m'a fait de la peine parce
que des gens moi quand j'écoute
quelqu'un je suis toujours agacé quand
on lui coupe systématiquement la parole
c'est vrai que la séquence était drôle
si on était à l'extérieur mais j'aurais
bien aimé effectivement qu'il aille
jusqu'au bout même si je partage pas la
passion pour à vous je suis d'accord
avec gréement là où jean michel et
benjamin que j'aime beaucoup auraient dû
s'arrêter
c'est quand ils ont senti que dans
l'esprit des gens ça devenait un débat
paris la région paris marseille
moi ya plein de gens qui m'ont dit
michael james moi je suis pas du tout
choquée par ce qui s'est passé hier faut
certes le concept de tpm paix l'adn de
tpm pc de se vanner entre nous et vous
vous seriez vous venez de faire une
chanson qui s'appelle isa l'adjoint
wendy je me fais cannes etc
et c'est très drôle il a mais ça m'a
fait marrer elle dans sa va faire le
clip avec moi ce mois là et vous allez
loin vous le faites plusieurs faux etc
ça fait marrer tout le monde après moi
j'adore rené schwok c'est un excellent
chroniqueur est sûr d'une chose qui fait
les meilleures recrues ouais je sens
qu'il va respecter les anciens foire du
respect pour ses aînés mais j'ai pas
compris en fait sa réaction parce que
c'est marrant de se vanner s'est pas non
plus gravissime ce qu'on a fait on a
rigolé pendant qu'il parlait parce que
ce qui est drôle en fait c'est pas son
accent c'est pas le fait qu'ils viennent
de province et juge qu'il est à fond il
est corps et âme avec didier raoult
c'est ça qui était un peu marrant oui il
apparaît que je n'ai pas égaux face à
l'humour trash grâce à l'auto dérision
oui mais sa sensibilité et tout ça moi
moi je trouve que la force de tp mpc sa
fragilité c'est à dire qu'on était en
direct hier et au bout d'un moment le
soir en une heure finalement l'émission
a changé vous avez vous vous êtes quand
même le maître des horloges le maître du
sommaire et finalement on n'a pas parlé
de ce qu'on devait pas de fin d'études
parce que sur raul c'était exceptionnel
avec les intérêts dont et rené redéfinir
ils nous appellent aujourd hui donc on
fait de la télé aussi une fête de la
télé et donc à un moment donné aussi où
on a tous remis des pièces dans le
jukebox
c'était assez marrant vie de cette
chose-là challenge for me que moi ou les
olives et après je pense que c'était pas
malveillant alors rené
va venir nous voir benjamin et jomby
aussi bons les a que tout de suite
benjamin rené et jean michel michaud
avec sont là merci aux ied a bien il a
bien tenu de leurs ébats en plus ainsi
quand on est bon vous avez écouté tout
ce qui s'est dit sur vous benjamin déjà
démarré par vous et ça aurait fait
crisser les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui
puisque vous en avez pris par les
créanciers privés alors souri hier
quelques choses soient bien claires il
ya il ya eu un début de séquence qui
était le suivant et c'est rené est un
personnage haut en couleur je dédie il
est extrêmement drôle je respecte
beaucoup
il est athée pmp on est une famille et
c'est vrai que le serbe se chambrent ce
bad moi je suis un pétomane j'ai divorcé
de 17 fois j'en prends plein la gueule
je comprends très bien que rené pas ce
recul met sur hier soir précisément
l'enchaînement était le suivant et cyril
et moi on est très complices et sa garde
et pas parce que on se moquer d'eux de
rené sait qu il enchaîné le stif et le
docteur tartarin et resserré mois moi
quand ça commence comme ça avec cyril
l'enseignant direct 8 en mai en direct
eh ben je plonge s'était pas contre eux
rené c'est pas du tout contre eux rené
effectivement ses prix et comme on est
des salles vérité les spectateurs l'ont
pris et s'est dit puissant homme de
radio et honnêtement c'est pas du tout
autre rené et honnêtement quand je hais
la séquence après le dérapé c'est vrai
qu'on est on remet des pièces genre mais
des pièces on va les faire je connais
parce qu'on est des sales gosses et que
moi je me marre et qu'effectivement plus
je vois rhône est énervé et puis je
rigole parce que c'est parce que je suis
comme ça et c'était pas du tout on peut
s'était même pas sur le propos de relais
parce que qu'ils aiment ou non le
professeur août je vous dis franchement
comme il irait vite je m'en bats les
couilles mais c'est pas propre aux le
proposer tel enchaînement de deux mots
qui était très drôle le stif en plus
avec ce week end le stif qui lhermitte
27 fois le sol voilà après sa prévention
je comprends que cornet tt était vexé
après tu fais un tweet ou d'une traité
d'abruti que ça ou je ne réponds pas
exprès et derrière je te jure que c'est
vrai les conséquences de ça c'est que
moi j'en prends plein la gueule mais pas
ta gueule on menace de tuer ma famille
du dossier des enfants de déterrer ma
mère ma grand mère il est nommé après je
dis attendre qu'est-ce qu'est ce que
j'ai fait moi parce que j'ai ri parce
que j'ai ri on va mener sainement et là
je suis pas d'accord et là je te lis
droit dans les yeux là je suis pas
d'accord parce que effectivement avec ce
tweet tu tournes est pas rendu compte
la manche le feu nucléaire et moi je
suis pas ici pour me faire insulter tu
vas ici pour me faire menacer de mort et
j'ai pas essayé pour me faire insulter
pendant des années et je regrette
sincèrement du fond du coeur si j'étais
blessé parce que c'est pas du tout toi
je voulais baissé en revanche je
regrette sincèrement du fond du coeur
les conséquences de ce qui s'est passé
sur les réseaux que j'ai quitté parce
que l'on pouvait plus parce que moi
quand j'ai mes enfants qui fond en
larmes et qui paraît je suis comme toi
je pète un plomb et respectivement tu
n'es pas responsable moi non plus mais
faut pas que tu peux faut pas prendre
cette émission pour ce qu'elle n'est pas
on est une famille on est là pour
déconner et ça ne peut pas ça ne doit
pas aujourd'hui à l'heure actuelle qui
plus est avec tout ce qui s'est passé on
peut pas se faire insulter se ferment et
maçonnerie est ce que c'est le droit
qu'ont à droite c'est une émission l'été
est loin de là s'il peut pas faire ça et
c'est pas de toi après je comprends très
me soit énervé et je sais mais je
comprends que mes mille fois des mille
fois mais si j'avais dû m'énerver à
chaque fois qu'on s'est moqué de moi de
mes ex femme de ma famille de du fait
que j'ai des petits yeux que je pète etc
mais j'aurai d'alors alors j'aurai juste
un petit bémol à tuer c'est que prenait
grenelle à 73 ans bien sûr j'ai
évidemment voilà c'est pas pareil rhône
et c'est vrai qu'il a 73 ans et on a
tendance à l'oublier parce que mon rôle
était tellement aux jeunes on déconne
tellement avec toi on déconne pas
retenir les leçons on vas tu viens me
voir en leur sondés comme tous les deux
comme des fous et on a tendance à
oublier bien sûr eux j'aimerais un rené
il a 73 ans alors il les fait pas c'est
vrai qu'il est c'est une énorme rigolade
c'est vrai que c'est notre pote on
oublie qu'on a une différence d'âge
parce que c'est tellement notre pote que
va qu'on a oublié pourrait sortir avec
lui tout le temps et rigoler et qui
parce qu'on a l'impression qu'on admet
mal mais c'est vrai qu'il a il a hélas
son trésor le jean michel après je
voudrais entendre on est bien peu mais
j'aurais aimé jeanjean brest connaît
pour commencer et je veux dire tout ce
qui a été dit était vrai tout ce qu'ils
étaient des vrais y avait une part de
vérité dans chaque rue dans chaque
propos dans les excès dans le fait que
voilà on n'a que ça a été trop loin ça a
duré trop longtemps que les rats moi ce
que je veux dire c'est pas une seule
seconde j'ai imaginé dans l'émission que
qu'après l'émission ça pourrait avoir
une telle répercussion chez rené j'ai
pas pensé une seconde compte c'est qu'il
ait été blessé on s'est retrouvé en
géant juste l'an passé qui on s'est
quitté en loge il est tentant de se
rhabiller et judy bisous rené à demain
mais une seule semence une heure en
temps chez moi qui allait avoir des
répercussions dans sa vie familiale et
dans dans sa tête surtout voilà qu'il
allait le prendre mal extra donc puisque
je sais que la prime elle parce que ça
donc sincère et 100% honnête je m'en
excuse auprès auprès de rené s'était pas
évidemment le but moi quand je m'en
prends c'était je me prenais et je m'en
voudrai toujours j'arrêterai pas au
professeur raoul tu vois là parce que
c'est devenu une tête de
pour moi mais rené c'est parce qu'il
défend est tellement d'insistance que
vous vous défendez parvenait le défend
que renault et ça fait pas ça fait pas
de l'émission le d'émersion de du débat
alors et c'est ça qui fait le succès de
tpm pc que ce débat on a le droit de
tout dire et le renaudot aussi ça aurait
été trop bref bien sûr critiquer c'est
pas sa quête généraux ni d'en parler de
choisir ce qui a généré c'est qu'il ya
eu de la pression on se foutait de sa
gueule etc et je te le dis mort n'est
pas du tout c'est comment je t'aime et
tu sais qu'on se parle beaucoup tous les
deux et tous les deux on a toujours une
relation transparente tu peux le dire on
se dit ou s'écrit on se dit les trucs
tout ça je te dis moi tu étais vraiment
devenu un pote c'est vrai donc voilà
après que tu restes dans l'émission bien
sûr ça me fait extrêmement plaisir que
je décide d'arrêter l'émission ça me
fera de la peine mais joue avant tout on
reste des potes tous les deux parce que
tu sais que je t'adore vraiment et que
voilà je suis devenu voilà tu étais
devenu un vrai pote à moi et j adore te
retrouver et j'adore partager des choses
avec toi hier en fait tpp c'est vrai que
c'est assez réponse vannes regarde isa
et c'est vrai que rené hier il n'a pas
compris il a senti qu'on il a pensé
qu'en foot et de sa gueule et là il ya
plein de gens qui n'ont ni jusqu'où tu
de ta gueule comment tu peux
voilà cautionner ça et ça je peux
comprendre
rené qu'il était blessé je peux vous
dire que rené était très très blessé
hier j'ai plusieurs fois
et voilà donc rené aujourd'hui tu m'as
tu m'as laissé un message tu m'as dit
oui l'acteur la vma voilà parce que tu
avais un sentiment qui s'était moqué de
toi comment tu te sens aujourd'hui
alors j'étais lui je vois j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup discuté et ma famille tu aimais
avec ma femme on a parlé et il pleurait
quand tu sais que je t'aime fort ça fait
cinquante trois ans que je suis mariée
une femme adorable c'est la reine et de
mon essai familiale de voir ma femme on
commença que j'ai connues acquises à
elle avec aisance la nasa teddy d'avoir
pleuré quand cela et je n'ai pas
supporté
mais je comprends j'ai pas supporté
parler avec elle j'ai beaucoup parlé
avec mes enfants et mes petits-enfants
ma petite fille et qui attendent
barbara que j'embrasse dans ces troubles
mais j'ai parlé aussi je le dis je je je
peux le dire j'ai parlé aussi la banane
au rwanda alors avait s'il tient visas
belges avaient yann avec ta famille de
production voilà et g j'ai décidé de ne
pas insulter de pas grave et les choses
la bonne excuse et c'est très bien mais
moi voilà au début je comprenais on me
vanner elle et moi je disais qu'au maroc
il tente comment l'armée a laissé le
bizutage il déconne mais le bizutage ça
fait deux mois et demi passé que je suis
là il est trop alors j'ai accepté borde
le bonnet du passé germaine ses 1000
euros pour les enfants allaient très
bien la bagnole ça fait rigoler tout le
monde et même en même massa ferrari
même la famille s'est cassé revan tu
connais je sais pas
papy en céréales et tout ce qui était
les assassinats l'autre fois ap à côté
de ça tu parles toi donc ici que là et
tu rigole toujours mais toujours pour
n'importe quel sujet
rappelle-toi 4 qui a eu le sujet de
faire pisser qu'a connue sur elle avait
atterri jeudi matin des puits situé à 27
ans toman de ramon tu te c'est parce que
[Musique]
c'est une histoire qui
c'est la façon de vous le raconter un
personnage on est maire personnel
pâteuse excusant est drôle c'est extra
c'est tragique mais c'est tellement
drôle ce que tu fais que je verrai pas
ce que ça brille ça que c'est raconter
on arrête parce que rené rené le regard
soit pas comme toi mais pas tellement ce
que tu te moques de lui mais pas du c ur
résultats dire que tu as tu as tu un
personnage qu'il est facile de parler
mais pas rêver c'est ça qu'on aime pas
les couilles au balo du les chocs comme
nabeul et dire aux décisionnaires yanis
et sané mais non c'est ici ça qu'on aime
si tu connais que ma femme et moi style
et on accepte pas certain de chez moi si
ça te gêne territoire accepte pas on
n'accepte pas sa raison et pas tournées
le vire vire ont pâti de pouffer nom de
marseille les siècles tible mois pile
savez la vie que j'ai vécu à marseille
j'ai pas le raconter
il ya des côtés obscurs aussi je sais
c'est à travers des chansons ordinaires
c'est pas pour venir à sa sainteté de
travail mais c'est un ridiculisé par
rené humain que je connaissais pas il ya
trois mois
et voilà connaît on est justement c'est
jean michel et benjamins qui t'ont qui
ton énervé là dessus sur ça on est tu
sais qu'ici on vrai qu est quand même
celui voilà qui est tout le monde est
derrière toi mais je le sais la majeure
partie de ce plateau ici tu sais que
suis tout le temps derrière toi moi
aussi c'est adorable
ah oui je vous le dis le ring nicolas
que je connais que depuis qu'un fossé le
joint se régale à rigoler parce qu'il me
refais toi tout ça et les belles filles
qui a tout ça mais moi je me régalais ce
plateau mais après une fois que dd mais
la femme a pleuré je ne le supporte plus
enfin les lycées c'est la reine les
enfants ils sont tous les petits enfants
et moi je regarde ça j'ai dit j'ai put
elle ne réussit qu'à une jeune
américaine renée rené ironique rené tu
sais que je suis toujours là pour te
protéger sur plein de trucs à chaque
fois que tu m'as demandé quelque chose
est ce que je fais ce que je t'ai
s'étaient dit oui
non mais tu es patron de manuel jose
comme à chaque fois se détache avec toi
moi ce que je te propose c'est que non
mais on me propose rien
décider de rester calme voilà le temps à
insulter elle a donc dû rester digne
faire des marseillais cathy ses prix
malgré on m a dit si la situation digne
je mangeais de cette émission notamment
de faire tourner l'équipe ten tout
autour et moi je vais pas te manquer moi
non mais tout le monde y en a beaucoup
qui vont me manquer voilà je ne vais pas
les citer part je te le dis je manu et
cyril sonné je te fais des gros bisous à
6 mais bon on est on comprends moi ce
que je veux juste que tu sois toujours
avec naughty là dans le coeur et que tu
sois notre pote voilà non si la silla sa
femme et la famille et que ça fait mal à
la famille à la femme
il faut qu'ils partent ja c'est pas
c'est pas négociable c'est une seule
monnaie comme tu sais comme je t'aime
bien écoute moi rhône et tu sais comme
je t'aime bien et tu t'es pas
d'aujourd'hui moi je veux juste un truc
on est jeudi
voilà si tu as fait si ça blesse la
famille tata tout le week-end moi je
veux juste que ce week-end et lundi tu
nous redit que tu veux pas venir c'est
tout parce que c'est nous on regarde tu
partes d'humiliation quand on prend du
chocolat je t'ai dit réfléchir puis à
marseille qui joue mardi
non mais d'accord mais quand on parle il
parle d'humiliation c'est brel il a 73
ans il n'a pas le temps il est pas là
pour un projet de carrière ou pour faire
mousser ou coquet s'il revient il à gré
il vient pour kiffer honénou fertile
affectif et actif est avec nous aussi
bah oui c'est ça est-ce que ça va bien
l'aimer g soit 7 et 13 ans j'ai mené une
vie de fou j'ai jamais même qui meurent
de travail jamais été à maladie je
nourris ma famille aujourd'hui différent
j'ai envie d'en profiter sans avoir des
histoires à la coco un médecin
je ne supporte pas moi si les sous sols
indirect par ne le sait
sociaux parce qu'il n'ya pas que des
mecs hilton d'accord et moi lui dire
ouais les soussous sa cote trou du cul
ça venait d'être atteint je faisais le
dessoude hanouna rené vautier rictus de
secondes juste je vais bien dru et je
sais que tu as pris beaucoup de plaisir
avec nous juste pour et c'est vrai que
tu t'es régaler avec nous oui nicolas
rené je suis désolé je vais pas essayer
de 2,2 de thau convaincre de rester là
tout de suite je pense que sarko chose
qui s'est passé j'entends et je
comprends tout ce que tu lis et puis
alors la perception à l'extérieur
c'est-à-dire quand tu rentres chez toi
face à tes enfants tes petits-enfants
moi ta vie je la connais deux chauffeurs
de bus
gaston defferre je connais tous tes
combats et je respecte énormément rien
pour ça ce que je veux juste dire que je
travaille et je m'occupais des syndicats
j'ai des fans ou les marseillais j'ai
été révoqué parce que j'ai c'est que
c'est un papa de la rate et à reculer
la recrue derrière je le sais tout ça
mais bon le temps rend le temps je te
dis pas que des rues non on le ton y est
chiffres donnent une seconde vie et ben
moi rené je vais te demander de rester
pas ça fait pas longtemps que je suis là
et je te jure que j'ai eu un coup de
coeur pour toi et si pour ta femme est
ta famille tu as envie de si tu as envie
de les respecter par rapport à ce que tu
as vécu hier soir c'est là c'est cette
mise au point là qui était fait et ça
suffit tu étais obligé de partir pour ça
pour ta flamme cnr de personnes belle
comme un coeur mais c'est pas ça qui va
me chercher je comprends ce qu'elle a
fait une mise au point qui est personnel
qui a eu beaucoup beaucoup de répression
et c'est juste sur mission j'en suis
jamais sur twitter que j'ai envoyée à
cyril tuschi l'année un million trois
cent cinquante mille vu mais c'est bon
parolier hommage à l'armée et moi pour
voir jessica c'est le bateau il ya 8
marseillais 8 mai des amis des frères
des sur mes couilles petit dieu non ils
se sont couchés devant le préserve le
bureau du patron et je fais la réalisera
fait pendant une semaine et ce crime est
ce qu'avoir lui mais qu'il faut lagarde
l'a fait pour lui
dis toujours que tu parlais des amis
mais moi mes amis voilà c'est eux et ils
me regardent la et les embrasser r2 et
moi je suis sûr qu'ils sont fiers de moi
voilà je te le dis on est des gens juste
dire que moi évidemment je souhaiterais
qu'il reste rené ici je croyais qu'ils
savaient que je l'aimé il a mal
interprété voilà quelque chose qu'il a
mal supporté je le comprends très bien
et lui dire aussi que ce n'est pas une
bataille de marseille contre paris moi
j'ai plein d'amis mars et bon j'adore
justement cette rivale états qui
vivraient jamais dire non mais tu es
toujours marseille de s'abonner à la
normale
c'est pas une question de rivalité est
pas mort d'homme non plus genton touche
trop ça regrettable franchement j'en
suis désolé c'est toi ta famille ma
famille aussi parfois elle est blessée
par plein de choses vers moi aussi ça
arrive tout le temps comme sina bien
mais là c'est pas évident nettement une
famille moi j'étais moi je t'aime
beaucoup et c'est pas une question de
demis et crois moi c'est vrai qu'ils
sont déshonorés on est tous là pour
rigoler ma réflexion parfois pompeux se
vexer mais c'est la vie tpm peu après si
c'est compliqué pour toi je peux
l'entendre mais jamais crois moi bien à
aucun moment j'ai voulu emmener
t'humilier ni te rabaisser j'ai voulu
rigoler honnête j'aimerais j'aimerais
bien personnellement que tu restes et si
tu incites accepté de rester moi je te
promets train de mettre la [ __ ] douce
ce raout et la blague les blagues sur
ton d'actionnaires la juste heureux
n'est joué te dire un mot c'est que si
jamais tu décides vraiment de partir oui
trois mois qu'on va vraiment le
regretter
heureux te connaître
hier si tu partais ou si tu restes et
voilà c'était pour moi
voilà je sais ce que c'est ta famille
qui m'a dit aimer ça qui nous a dit
aimer ça toi c'est pour toi tu sais je
sais que tu adores le moyen-âge c'est
pour toi mais revoilà et uc rhône et que
quoi qu'il arrive
et quoi que tu décides tu sais que je
t'aime tu sais je serai toujours là pour
toi tu pourras m'appelant potes quand tu
le voudrais tu le sais ça et je sais que
toi et moi on a une relation
voilà qui qui perdurera quoi qu'il
arrive tu vois jusqu'où le temps parce
que j'ai promis à ma famille et j'ai le
pronom aussi aux promis aussi dans la
loge à cynthia isabelle vialle un fait
ils étaient quatre siècles surtout ne
comporte pas je me suis pas porter je
suis pas le temps je vous ai rien dire
j'avais pas si on a réussi à me
convaincre à me calmer c'est dur c'est
très dur de me calmer parce que quand je
suis parti je suis parti et la voilà et
ben voila merci pour le cadeau est aussi
à tout cela on a tendance à tout et je
te refais avec nikos qui voit là et je
reviens à marseille les amis qui le
bordaient madilu on ira se faire via
parisien